unhoused is the new latinx it's the hot
new pc lingo on the market and you want
to get in on the action before it
changes again because yesterday the word
was homeless today it's unhoused
tomorrow it might be I don't know
dehoused then it will be person of an
unhoused persuasion then eventually
habitation challenged and you'll realize
that all this sounds far too negative
still and they'll want a term that sends
the message that homeless people aren't
really homeless at all it's just that
they don't have one single home in a
fixed location right their home is
everywhere it changes they'll start
using terms like house fluid and
dwelling expensive that's where this
leads but for now unhoused is the new
trendy thing